[Aplausos]
[Música]
invito a los argentinos a sumarse a la
revolución liberal que va a ser que en
35 años Argentina vuelva a ser una
potencia mundial Muchas gracias y viva
la libertad Viva Viva la libertad
Viva Viva la libertad
dicen que si dudas pierdes y que si te
ves perdiendo acabas perdiendo eso al
menos es algo que mi ley parece que tuvo
claro desde muy pronto porque si yo
entro la segunda vuelta el próximo
presidente argentino soy yo si paso el
ballotage en la segunda vuelta le gano a
todos vale en cierto modo la grave
crisis económica que atraviesa la
Argentina ha sido toda una catapulta
para sus aspiraciones políticas Al fin y
al cabo hablamos primero de un tipo que
es economista de profesión y segundo de
un economista que tiene un plan de
cambio radical y que ha sabido Como
nadie señalar a quienes todos buscan los
grandes culpables del mal argentino las
encuestas no dan lugar a la duda los
argentinos están sedientos de cambio de
cambios radicales que sean capaces de
darle la vuelta al país como si fuera un
calcetín hoy nos hemos puesto de pie
para decirle basta al modelo de la
decadencia hoy dimos el primer paso para
la reconstrucción de Argentina por eso
Javier Gerardo Miley ha dejado de ser
una utopía una quimera un candidato
imposible para convertirse en el gran
favorito para hacerse con la presidencia
Argentina en su carpeta está
supuestamente el mayor programa de
reformas económicas y políticas de toda
la historia del país gaucho y es mucho
decir en unas elecciones donde todo
absolutamente todo gira en torno al
dinero y también en torno a la propia
figura de Javier Miley queréis una
prueba pues vosotros mismos massa contra
milei propone a justi de evaluación lo
disfraza con la dolarización jto
bullrich melconian señaló que su plan
económico está listo para desembarcar
con referencias indirectas hacia Javier
Miley el economista seguro que cuenta
con un plan realista implementable y que
no representa un salto al vacío qué os
voy a contar la dolarización ha marcado
la agenda electoral como nunca antes hoy
por hoy esta promesa se ha convertido en
el gran sueño del cambio que la
desaparición definitiva del peso ayude a
la Argentina a escapar de las tinieblas
por supuesto Esa no es su única Promesa
de corte económico Miley también ha
prometido una drástica reducción del
gasto público muchas menos regulaciones
y una agresiva liberalización comercial
junto a la dolarización estas tres ideas
se han convertido en el gran comodín de
un candidato Al que ya muchos ven en la
casa
[Música]
rosada puede resultar sorprendente visto
desde fuera de la Argentina pero hoy en
el país gaucho el plan de milei levanta
tanta pasión y tantas controversias como
si se tratara de un auténtico debate
futbolístico entre hinchas del boca y
del River Claro que en un país donde la
inflación supera el 120 por Lo raro es
que el dinero la economía y el futuro
del peso no fueran los grandes temas del
momento Qué importa todo lo demás si lo
que está en juego es el pan que llevarse
a la boca Claro que de todo esto ya se
ha hablado y mucho por eso la pregunta
la gran pregunta que nos hemos hecho es
muy clara que hay realmente en la agenda
de mi ley Más allá de los grandes
números y la economía cuáles son sus
planes si es que los hay en terrenos
como las infraestructuras la salud o la
educación cómo piensa abordar
exactamente la transición política que
conllevaría su enorme hoja de ruta al
margen de lo económico Que tanto se
diferencia mi ley del resto de la
oposición al peronismo Pues todo esto y
más lo vamos a ver a continuación
arranquemos Pero antes un momento te has
parado a pensar en lo que te estás
perdiendo por no usar Surf Shark lo
primero de todo y más importante es la
seguridad en la red con surfshark tu
actividad online está fuertemente
protegida cifrada y a salvo de ojos
curiosos además con Clean web te
despides de los anuncios y el malware Y
qué pasa con los emails te preguntarás
pueses con Surf Shark alert te enterarás
al instante si alguien ha intentado
filtrar tu información pero es que aún
hay más Surf Shark es la primera VPN
comercial con servidores en más de un
centenar de países vamos algo así como
un pasaporte global a golpe de click
podrás acceder a cualquier contenido
bloqueado por ubicación Y si te preocupa
tener que elegir en Qué dispositivo
usarlo tranquilos con la misma cuenta
puedes proteger todos tus dispositivos
ya sea tu móvil tu tablet la tele o el
ordenador sin límites Esto hace que
puedas compartir la cuenta con tus
mejores amigos por ejemplo así entre
todos cada uno pagaré unos pocos
céntimos al mes además por ser parte de
la comunidad visual politic podrá
disfrutar de TR meses extra totalmente
gratis usando el código politic acabado
en K y dicho esto continuemos con
nuestro vídeo de
hoy salud y educación cambio lento pero
cambio
seguro vale creo que todos lo tenemos
más o menos claro el plan de mi ley al
menos por ahora contempla una enorme ola
de transformación de la República
Argentina o mejor dicho del Estado
argentino lo que en el país gaucho viene
a ser prácticamente lo mismo en este
sentido salud y educación dejarán de ser
ministerios para convertirse en
secretarías dentro de un macr Ministerio
de capital humano que coordine todas las
acciones que tengan que ver con la
asistencia social sí lo habéis pillado
Esta es una de esas tretas que consisten
en reducir unos organismos para crear
otros y al final seguir más o menos
igual así que pasemos de esta cuestión y
vayamos directamente a lo importante lo
que propone mi ley es esencialmente un
nuevo modelo de financiación donde el
gobierno subvencion la demanda y no
directamente la oferta También queremos
dejar Claro que nuestra visión el mejor
sistema de salud posible es un sistema
de salud privado donde cada argentino
pague sus servicios el mejor sistema
educativo posible es uno donde cada
argentino pague por sus servicios Esto
es así no es debatible Es decir que la
educación y la sanidad sigan siendo
mayormente servicios gratuitos para los
argentinos pero que estos pued elegir el
centro que les provea estos servicios el
objetivo sería que poco a poco fuera
surgiendo un mercado cada vez más
competitivo y cada vez con Más oferentes
sin embargo hay un pequeño
inconveniente incluso Más allá del reto
que supondría ligar la financiación de
los centros públicos a la demanda en el
sistema argentino tanto la salud como la
educación no Universitaria están en
manos de las provincias es decir que el
cambio para ser siquiera posible tendría
que ser todavía más grande y sabéis que
esto es lo que explica el gradualismo
que manifiestan los propios referentes
de milei sobre estos temas fijaos los
subsistemas públicos privados y de la
seguridad social seguirán los hospitales
seguirán funcionando igual pero tendrán
que hacerlo con una mejor gestión lo
harán en cada distrito y como lo decida
cada jurisdicción pero con la
universalización de la cobertura que
todo el mundo tenga un seguro y con
prestaciones posibles de esta forma a
nivel de salud mi ley se prometido a
instaurar un seguro médico universal que
fuese financiado por el estado ese sería
el primer paso luego poco a poco la
financiación de los centros iría
dependiendo del nivel de demanda de cada
centro Lo que les obligaría a competir
entre sí aunque fueran centros públicos
Claro que habría que ver qué incentivos
tendrían a competir lo lógico es que un
nivel de demanda mayor en un centro
supusiera salarios más altos para sus
profesionales pero hablamos de Argentina
no parece fácil luego en educación los
equipos equipos de la libertad avanza
plantean iniciativas similares la
entrega del voucher podría hacerse por
medio de una tarjeta con una cuenta como
la educational savings accounts que
funcionan en algunos estados de Estados
Unidos con esta tarjeta el estudiante
paga la cuota de un colegio público
privado se buscaría llegar algún acuerdo
con alguna provincia que esté dispuesta
a avanzar en la reforma de paso serviría
de ejemplo hacia las demás las que tal
vez luego querrían avanzar en ese
sentido el problema como veis es que
aquí vuelven a surgir las provincias sin
las provincias no hay nada que
hacer luego Más allá de estos grandes
cambios estructurales los planes de
milei también contemplan otras reformas
de menor calibre Como por ejemplo una
reforma de la ley de Educación que
permita hacer públicos los resultados de
las pruebas de desempeño tanto de
alumnos como de maestros de todos los
establecimientos educativos es decir
introducir evaluaciones realmente
efectivas que influyan en la búsqueda de
centros en cualquier caso ya lo veis más
allá de los grandes titulares no está
claro que a corto y medio plazo los
planes de Miley supusieron muchos
cambios los cheques educativos y de
salud pueden ser una gran idea pero no
está claro que puedan tener grandes
efectos reales el riesgo es que
cualquier cambio que pueda tocar los
salarios de los empleados públicos
termine como el rosario de la Aurora y
que de no hacerlo la medida no sirva
para prácticamente nada Claro que esto
es tan solo el
comienzo
el debate de la
seguridad durante el gobierno de Alberto
Fernández No se puede decir que la
vicepresidencia haya tenido un rol
precisamente irrelevante a cargo de
Cristina Fernández de kirner la
vicepresidencia tuvo por momentos
muchísima visibilidad y muchísima
influencia hasta el punto de desatar una
feroz guerra interna dentro del
oficialismo es decir que ahora la
vicepresidencia se percibe como un
órgano mucho más relevante de como se
veía hace apenas unos pocos años Pues
bien en este sentido Javier Miley optó
por Victoria villarruel como compañera
de Fórmula A ella le ha encomendado
además la gestión de todos los temas
relativos a seguridad y defensa
Argentina amigos ha sido y sigue siendo
un país relativamente seguro al menos
para los cánones que se manejan en
América Latina pese a ello en los
últimos años los tentáculos del
narcotráfico se están extendiendo por
todo el país y en general por todo el
cono sur este será sin duda uno de los
grandes retos del nuevo gobierno
Argentina Busca reforzar la justicia
contra la escalada de violencia narco en
Rosario lucha contra el narcotráfico
Uruguay y Paraguay refuerzan los
controles en sus puertos tras las
medidas que implementó Argentina en este
escenario la libertad avanza tiene
varias propuestas algunas de ellas tan
polémicas como esta sobre la tenencia de
armas de fuego planteamos la
desregulación del mercado legal y
proteger su uso legítimo y responsable
por parte de la ciudadanía Claro que con
el tiempo sobre esta cuestión en
particular han surgido algunas
contradicciones se ve con Claridad o sea
los lugares donde la gente anda Calzada
la delincuencia es menor o sea vos estás
a for que la gente se arme digamos sí
por qué no O sea el mercado de armas lo
liberaría Sí por ejemplo la aportación
de armas que es un tema que usted
instaló en la campaña lo va a
implementar pronto yo no lo instalé la
campaña ni siquiera está en la
plataforma no está en la plataforma
luego el tema de la libre portación de
armas fue desplazado de la agenda
libertaria al tiempo que villarruel se
ha posicionado como la exponente de una
nueva doctrina de seguridad denominada
el que las hace las paga una reforma que
alcanza a la ley de seguridad interior a
la ley de defensa nacional y a la ley de
inteligencia vamos a reforzar el
esfuerzo de la Policía Nacional
respaldando las acciones de las fuerzas
del orden potenciando el Consejo de
Seguridad interior Además de que vamos a
recurrir a la figura del comité de
crisis que está estipulada para para las
emergencias en la ley de seguridad
interior la idea con la que trabaja el
equipo de milei pasa por endurecer las
penas y los márgenes de actuación de las
fuerzas de seguridad mientras que en lo
que respecta a las cárceles se plantea
la construcción de nuevas prisiones de
gestión público-privada donde los
reclusos puedan incluso participar en
jornadas laborales Claro que en cuestión
de seguridad el plan de la libertad
avanza no solo tiene grandes similitudes
sino que va Incluso en desventaja En
comparación con la candidatura de
Patricia
[Música]
bullrich bullrich ejerció como ministra
de seguridad de Mauricio macri entre
2015 y 2019 y en cierta forma puso en
práctica buena parte del cambio de
paradigma y las reformas a las que ahora
apunta villarruel lo que lógicamente le
da una cierta ventaja aunque solo sea
por tener más experiencia en el campo
los Derechos Humanos son para los
delincuentes las leyes son para los
delincuentes eh el el código penal
actual que nosotros lo quisimos cambiar
y no lo permitieron son para los
delincuentes decir protegen
permanentemente a los delincuentes y
desprotege a los ciudadanos y lo peor de
todo desprotege a quienes nos cuidan sea
como sea las estrategias planteadas en
materia de seguridad salud y educación
mantienen una línea más o menos
coherente y digo esto porque luego en el
resto de propuestas podemos encontrar
posiciones mucho más heterogéneas que en
algunos casos para muchos escapan
incluso de las fronteras liberales está
Endo el león sabotajes dentro de casa
pues
atentos infiltraciones de la casta O
teorema de
baglini queridos amigos amigas digamos
que a principios de este 2023 el perfil
político de Javier Miley no era tan
atractivo como lo puede ser hoy para
todos aquellos profesionales y
referentes políticos que buscaban alguna
plataforma a la cual unirse Y eso eso
fue algo que de alguna forma provocó un
batiburrillo un conglomerado de perfiles
muy heterogéneos que se fueron sumando a
la libertad avanza que es exactamente lo
que explica noticias como estas denunció
una funcionaria de Axel kissiov que es
candidata de Javier Miley la candidata
también figura en el organigrama del
gobierno buenoaires como directora de
servicios auxiliares del Ministerio de
transporte de la provincia de Buenos
Aires una cartera del gobierno de Axel
kicillof que está a cargo de Rodolfo
donofrio un hombre de Sergio masa Quién
es Miguel Ángel ponte el exun macrista
que podría ser secretario de trabajo si
Javier Miley es presidente grabó y se
aseguró que Miley armó las listas con
toda la gente de masa el ex precandidato
presidencial de Unión por la patria Juan
grabois sostuvo las últimas horas que
Javier Miley logró armar las listas en
todo el país con toda gente de masa no
me cabe la menor duda de que no son
enemigos acérrimos sostuvo este tipo de
situaciones han generado algunas
contradicciones y también algunas dudas
sobre las intenciones del candidato en
relación con los sindicatos o una
eventual reforma
laboral por ejemplo el programa de la
plataforma de milei propone eliminar las
indemnizaciones por despido o reformar
de arriba abajo los sindicatos Claro que
ahora estas cosas son descartadas por el
propio milei será una cuestión de que
tendrán que resolver ellos internamente
de cómo por qu esto funciona así okay
pero no te parece algo que hay que
también romper En ese sentido Pero de
vuelta eso es un problema que tienen que
resolver los sindicalistas digo no tengo
porque está rompiendo yo Una institución
problema es que no es ningún secreto que
los sindicatos en Argentina son una
institución con enorme poder capaz de
paralizar cualquier aparato productivo
de forma casi indefinida por lo que este
cambio de rumbo quizás no resulta tan
inesperado Javier Miley se mostrará con
Luis barrio nuovo y afianza su vínculo
con un sector del sindicalismo el
sindicalista que hasta hace menos de dos
meses apoyaba al kisnerista Eduardo guad
de Pedro en la carrera presidencial y
después de las pasos Se comprometió con
el libertario invitó a varios de sus
pares gremiales y a una decena de
empresarios a parque que Norte donde se
mostrarán Juntos por primera vez y es
justo aquí donde muchos encuentran que
la existencia del teorema de bini tiene
plena
vigencia en
1986 en plena Primavera democrática el
entonces diputado argentino Raúl baglini
expuso una serie de premisas que se
reconocerían posteriormente como el
teorema de baglini este teorema consiste
principalmente en la siguiente idea la
responsabilidad de las propuestas
políticas es directamente proporcional a
las chances que se tiene de llegar al
poder
[Música]
es decir que Cuanto más cerca te ves del
Poder más continuista te vuelves y justo
esta ha sido la acusación que muchos
argentinos han comenzado a realizar
contra ciertos giros de la libertad
avanza hacia una cierta moderación
digamos que como dicen por ahí no es lo
mismo Llamar al que verlo llegar
y ahora que las puertas de la casa
rosada están cada vez más abiertas Al
arribo de mi ley la gobernabilidad
comienza a ser un tema
prioritario
aquí entonces encontramos dos
posibilidades bien diferentes una es que
el gabinete libertario está comenzando a
enfriar el exponencial idealismo
manifestado en la campaña de las pasadas
primarias la otra es considerar que la
inserción de huérfanos políticos tanto
del kissnerismo como de Juntos por el
cambio en los equipos políticos de milei
están generando algunas distorsiones
respecto al ideario libertario esto
último podría llegar a representar una
peligrosa paradoja para la ecuación de
gobierno de la libertad avanza Al fin y
al cabo no es un secreto para nadie que
Javier Miley Ha logrado colgar un cartel
encima de todos los políticos argentinos
con una palabra clave
casta claro que también existe una
tercera posibilidad que explique por qué
la candidatura de Miley podría llegar a
adoptar posiciones menos rupturistas
como ya hemos visto las reformas de la
educación y la sanidad requieren
acuerdos con los gobiernos provinciales
y locales al tiempo que la nueva
doctrina de seguridad también
necesitaría un amplio acuerdo
legislativo es exactamente lo mismo que
ya se ha planteado con las reformas
económicas mi ley necesitará a la casta
para poder gobernar Y eso explica que
algunos grandes temas incluso los
grandes temas estrella poco a poco
corran el riesgo de terminar enfriándose
Carlos Rodríguez se distanció de la
dolarización que plantea Emilio campo no
se puede hacer en este momento es
discutible el plan de campo en el
pizarrón está perfecto el teorema es si
políticamente el congreso lo va a votar
Y si en la práctica esos activos el
mercado va a considerar que valen algo
Yo no estoy de acuerdo la
metodología en el caso de ganar para
dolarizar no la tienen cerrada no hay
varias metodologías por ejemplo esta
metodología es la más fácil nosotros nos
sentamos con fondos de inversión de alto
riesgo y están dispuestos a poner los
3000 millones de dólares contra están
dispuestos nad quiere prestar Argentina
pero sígame el argumento de momento si
podemos decir algo Es que la opinión
pública Argentina está partida en torno
a mi
ley 50% de los argentinos piensan que
Argentina mejorará mucho o algo al
tiempo que el 45 por considera que el
país estará peor tras 4 años de mi ley
como presidente sea como sea ya lo veis
más allá de la dolarización y la reforma
económica el equipo de Miley también
plantea importantes cambios en materia
de Educación sanidad y seguridad El
problema es que aquí las propuestas y
los posibles resultados son todavía más
difusos el nivel de incertidumbre es
mucho mayor la pregunta que ahora nos
podría amos a hacer es vale Esto es lo
que persigue hacer con la Argentina Pero
y de puertas para fuera Qué pasará con
mercosur con Brasil con China o con las
relaciones con Washington Pues todo eso
y más lo veremos en una próxima entrega
aquí en visual politic ahora si este
vídeo te ha resultado interesante No
olvides darle al botón de like y
suscribirte a este canal si es que aún
no lo has hecho y recordad con el código
politic acabado en K podré disfrutar de
tres meses extra totalmente gratis con
sursat el link como siempre abajo en la
descripción un saludo y hasta la
[Música]
próxima